[Musique]
c'est un constat auquel les Français se
sont habitués
donc je sais pas comment les gens vont
faire et cela ne devrait pas s'arranger
en mars comment expliquer ces nouvelles
hausses le premier mars les négociations
entre les industriels d'un côté
autrement dit les fournisseurs les
marques et la grande distribution de
l'autre prendront fin à cette date les
nouveaux prix seront fixés pour limiter
ces hausses une solution est sur la
table le panier anti-inflation proposé
par le gouvernement objectif déprime
bloqués sur une cinquantaine de produits
à compter de la mi-mars alors je
voudrais redonner la définition de
l'inflation à l'inflation c'est la perte
du pouvoir d'achat qui se traduit par
une augmentation générale et durable des
prix c'est une définition de l'INSEE en
gros toutes les dépenses des ménages
augmentent en raison de la hausse des
prix forcément
aujourd'hui donc
Eric Revel pourquoi le ministre de
l'Économie nous dit qu'il y aura pas
d'Octobre Rouge de mars rouges
c'était un chiffre sur un sous-marin
je pense dans son rôle Bruno Le Maire il
essaie de d'expliquer aux Français
qu'ils ont pas de points de problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat mais en réalité oui mais
un moment quand ils vont au supermarché
les Français voilà mais en réalité on le
voit bien depuis aller 1 an les prix
alimentaires ont augmenté en France de
14 % sur un an 14 % et pour l'instant on
pense qu'ils vont augmenter de 10 %
supplémentaires donc ça ferait 24 % avec
ce morceau oui 10% ça c'est pour les
plus optimistes Cyril il y a d'autres
experts qui pensent que ça peut
augmenter plus encore les prix
alimentaires il y a les profiteurs de la
crise il y a aussi des gens alors les
professeurs les profiteurs de la crise
c'est des gens qui
savent qu'il y a une inflation forte une
hausse des prix forte en ce moment en
France et qui augmente les prix de leurs
produits par exemple si vous regardez
dans le détail vous verrez que la
nourriture pour chat par exemple ou pour
chien augmenter de 30 ou 40 % oui voilà
vous avez des prix de première des
produits de première nécessité l'huile
le sucre qui ont augmenté à deux
chiffres 20 ou 30% et vous avez raison
quand on fait une animalier 41%, 41% et
quand vous faites vos courses vous
rendez bien compte qu'il y a un vrai
problème ça veut dire qu'il y a de plus
en plus de familles qui sont difficultés
pour se nourrir de plus en plus de
familles et ça se traduit par un truc
très simple c'est que les banques
populaires ou les Restos du Coeur sont
submergés par des gens qui viennent de
leur demander des produits pour se
nourrir qui n'avaient jamais vu jusqu'à
présent donc au-delà de la réforme des
retraites c'est un autre sujet la hausse
des prix ça vient un sujet vraiment
central en France parce que encore une
fois il y a plein de familles qui ne
peuvent plus se nourrir correctement et
ça va avoir d'autres implications très
fortes à moyen terme je veux pas être le
négatif de la soirée mais si vous
nourrissez mal ou si vous ne pouvez plus
vous nourrir correctement mal c'est à
dire bouffer n'importe quoi et ne plus
manger correctement mais vous allez
aussi développer des maladies et tout ça
ça se retrouve à plus tard donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une situation
d'urgence vraiment et malheureusement je
pense qu'on va voir un mars rouge alors
est-ce que ça sera une hausse de 10% ou
de plus bah on le verra c'est-à-dire
qu'à chacun quand on passe 10%
les plus optimistes disent 10%. mais il
y a des gens qui disent des experts qui
disent ça peut aller de 20 à 30% sur
certains produits oui Mathieu oui on dit
que l'inflation c'est le cancer de
l'économie et que du coup l'inflation va
faire en sorte qu'il y avait une hausse
des taux d'intérêt donc une baisse de
l'immobilier donc une baisse des
délicatement est-ce qu'on se dirige vers
une crise économique bah on est on est
dans une forme de crise économique on
est dans une forme de crise économique
déjà les taux d'intérêt remontent très
fortement très fortement très fortement
donc ça veut dire que c'est très
compliqué d'emprunter quand vous
cherchez un logement et quand vous avez
donc là aujourd'hui le marché immobilier
est figé bien sûr voilà donc forcément
voilà il y a plus de transactions c'est
vrai que là il a les taux d'intérêts
pour répondre
il y a aussi un autre truc c'est que le
principal moteur de la croissance en
France c'est la consommation des ménages
c'est la consommation des ménages si les
gens ne peuvent plus acheter ça veut
dire qu'ils consomment plus et ça veut
dire donc que l'économie française
risque d'être sur une pente extrêmement
descendante pour l'instant on échappe à
la récession
la récession c'est une croissance qui
n'est plus positive qui devient une
croissance négative c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne crée plus de richesse on en perd et
on y va alors pour l'instant on évite la
récession mais si la consommation
continue de baisser à cause de
l'inflation bah les gens consomment
moins comme je vous le disais c'est le
principal argument de la croissance
française la consommation c'est pas les
exportations c'est pas ce qu'on vend bah
si cette consommation tombe bah la
croissance est résistera pas donc on va
se trouver dans une situation économique
qui peut être une crise économique voire
une récession bon c'est pas des supers
nouvelles alors ça fait déjà quelques
semaines qu'on s'attend un mois de mars
terrible beaucoup de gens le dit écoutez
Michel Biron le patron des achats et du
marketing d'une grande enseigne et
regardez ce qu'il dit on a aujourd'hui
sur la table des hausses entre 15 et
49%. donc même si on fait notre travail
de négociateur bien évidemment on va
passer des hausses et donc c'est beau
cela vont s'appliquer à partir du 1er
mars il y a des produits il y aura un
peu de stock donc peut-être le 1er avril
le 15 etc donc ça va s'étaler je pense
effectivement jusqu'au mois de juin on a
rien vu encore alors les plus forts sont
devant nous bien sûr probablement
certaines marques vont disparaître
peut-être des rayons parce que quand on
nous demande 49 % de sans aucune
justification exemple très clairement je
ne continuerai pas avec ce produit là
alors justement là il dit que ça
pourrait durer jusqu'en juin ça va durer
là aussi ça varie Bruno Le Maire et le
gouvernement avait dit en mars on aura
passé le plus gros là maintenant on dit
que c'est plutôt à l'été qu'il faut
s'attendre encore à des hausses de prix
mais où je disais tout à l'heure Cyril
que les distributeurs et les industriels
se tiennent un peu par la barbichette
c'est que quand vous avez un produit à
vendre si vous n'êtes pas référencé chez
Carrefour chez Leclerc chez Lidl ou
ailleurs bah votre chiffre d'affaires il
s'effondre donc il faut trouver un
terrain d'entente sur les prix le
problème c'est qu'entre les
distributeurs et les industriels qui va
payer la facture ben nous les
consommateurs étant là il dit qu'il y a
des marques qui va disparaître c'est
parce qu'elles seront plus différencer
parce que parce qu'ils ne voulons plus
les mettre en rayon l'idole c'est c'est
une marque de ce qu'on appelle de
arrondissement c'est-à-dire de prix
casser mais pour d'autres
prenez une boisson très connue que je
vais pas citer c'est à la fois une
capsule et la fois une bouteille de
verre ben pour faire du vert il faut de
l'énergie et pour faire la capsule en
aluminium il faut aussi de l'énergie ça
veut dire que le produit en tant que tel
il a pas vraiment augmenté mais le
contenant il a augmenté donc évidemment
les industriels ils répercutent toutes
ces séances de prix et le consommateur
il va avoir du mal à suivre enfin on le
voit mais en ce moment
quand Macron a fait le covid 140
milliards lorsqu'il a il a fait marcher
la planche à billets et se doutait bien
derrière que plus on met de billets plus
adaptation derrière parce que la monnaie
perd de la valeur il savait ça il est
pas idiot il est banquier
c'était logique c'est la Banque centrale
européenne
qui a racheté des dettes françaises
puisqu'on était obligé de soutenir à ce
moment-là vous souvenez au moment du
covid il y avait du chômage partiel vous
avez des gens en difficulté heureusement
qu'on a eu ces amortisseurs sociaux mais
l'argent magique n'existe pas donc la
banque centrale a racheté la dette
française elle a beaucoup créé une
monnaie et l'une des raisons de
l'inflation aussi c'est la création
monétaire une simple technique pour
revenir sur les négociations que vous
évoquiez entre les marques et les
distributeurs et les distributeurs oui
les distributeurs ils ont peut-être
quand même un levier à jouer parce que
si effectivement ils disent on vous
référence plus bah les profiteurs ils
vont essayer de ils vont plus profiter
on leur dit là vous faites n'importe
quoi 40% c'est impossible évidemment ça
doit monter vos prix on le comprend mais
40% vous allez beaucoup trop loin donc
c'est peut-être eux qui peuvent
éventuellement tordre c'est toute la
négo en fait en ce moment enfin qui
s'est terminé entre les distributeurs et
les industriels moi je me garderai bien
de vous dire que seuls les industriels
poussent à la hausse des prix et que les
distributeurs voilà regardent ça de loin
en disant le pauvre consommateur donc je
veux méfie un peu mais mais en réalité
moi je le dis comme je le pense Cyril le
consommateur vous avez de plus en plus
de familles aujourd'hui qui ont du mal à
acheter des produits bien sûr vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure du panier
anti-inflation lancée par le
gouvernement alors ça pouvait apparaître
comme une bonne idée sauf que là ça a
l'air d'être complètement enterré Olivia
Grégoire qui avait mis ça sur la table
visiblement pas de directivation c'était
quoi c'était de dire on va sélectionner
tiens 10 20 30 produits de première
nécessité alimentation produits
d'hygiène et on va obliger les
distributeurs les grandes enseignes à
avoir des prix cassés bon mais le
problème de la distribution c'est qu'ils
sont concurrents entre eux et la plupart
d'entre eux ont déjà lancé leur panier
anti-inflation c'est du marketing c'est
de la publicité bon donc les les effets
un peu d'annonces de communication du
gouvernement pour l'instant c'est pas la
solution pour les consommateurs les
consommateurs ce qu'ils avaient
consommateurs je vais dire ce qu'ils
attendent moi je le vois tous les tweets
là qui tombent c'est j'avais un truc à 1
€ maintenant il est à 4 euros un truc à
2 euros il a 7 euros là il voit bien que
ça ça je vais te dire je pense que quand
on dit
voilà une augmentation globale de
combien on a eu des 10%. 10% pour le
mois de mars je pense que moi je pense
que c'est déjà plus je pense que c'est
déjà plus vraiment je le vois sur les
prix c'est tout simple on le voit c'est
tu peux comparer le caddie que tu
faisais avant exactement le même Maxence
voilà c'est doux moi je pense qu'on est
déjà on est déjà un peu plus je pense
qu'on doit être entre 15 et beaucoup les
gens aussi c'est qu'il y a un calcul
officiel de l'inflation vous savez c'est
l'Insee l'Insee
l'inflation en France serait à 6% en ce
moment mais en réalité dans dans les
produits qui sont pris en compte dans ce
panier de l'Insee c'est des produits
qu'on achète pas tous les jours un
ordinateur on s'en fout de savoir que le
prix augmente ou baisse en revanche la
farine le riz les pâtes sur l'Insee
calcule pas c'est indice donc c'est ça
parce qu'en fait il faudrait qu'il y ait
deux calculs les produits
les produits qu'on achète pas souvent
parce que là si tu si tu fais la moyenne
globale forcément
elle est fausse elle est Gilles oui tu
veux dire un truc vu la situation le
gouvernement parfois donne des aides il
y a le chèque énergie sur le les prix du
carburant étant d'agir pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a pas un système la d'urgence
parce que les gens quand ils vont au
supermarché aujourd'hui ils font une
fois les courses et le 10 de moins ils
peuvent plus remplir leurs caddie les
prix de consommation courante explose ça
recréer l'inflation mais pourquoi il y a
pas une aide là un chèque alimentaire
une idée d'avoir une sorte de chèque
alimentaire qui a été supplanté par ce
panier anti-inflation qui voit pas le
jour et pendant ce temps-là la façon
continue direct il y aurait peut-être
une mesure mais qui serait intéressante
c'est très simple c'est de sélectionner
les prix les produits dont on a le plus
besoin pour vivre et de baisser le taux
de TVA
première nécessité ça ça pourrait être
en train d'en parler ça ça pourrait être
un commentaire
une dernière question oui justement je
voulais parler du Best de la TVA parce
que plus il y a d'inflation plus la
partie de la TVA augmente donc c'est
incompréhensible qui ne baisse pas comme
vous venez de le dire sur les produits
les produits de non non mais justement
pourquoi ne le font-ils pas c'est une
bonne question mais le grand profiteur
comme de la crise actuelle c'est l'état
parce que quand vous avez des prix qui
augmentent avec un taux de TVA en fait
les recettes de TVA sont plus
importantes